well i'm joined now sitting right next
to me by someone that perhaps you've
heard of if you're a fox fan tucker
carlson is host of tucker carlson
tonight weeknights 8 pm eastern on fox
news channel also tucker carlson today
and tucker carlson originals at fox
nation you can find out more at
foxnation.com or tuckercarlson.com
you're very busy they have you doing
many things tucker i can't believe i'm
on a show sponsored by a finnish booze
company that is the coolest thing that's
ever happened to me well i'm glad that
we can be i love finland i'm actually
part finish
and
the finns no booze they do
yeah they do and this has been the most
popular alcoholic beverage there for
like 70 years it's like guinness is to
ireland as long drink is to finland and
they sponsor the show and it's really
good that's right so it's such a great
country it's a wonder it's a wonderful
country i think i want to start with
just some like
almost shop talk because whenever i'm
out meeting people and chatting with fox
viewers around the country when i'm
traveling
many times people ask about you oh
tucker what's he like you know his show
it's been such a huge success
it got me thinking because you've been
in this business for a while now you've
been at cnn crossfire 26 years the
bowtie days and msnbc of course and at
fox different roles here at fox and now
this prime time show that has just been
like a rocket ship this massive success
not taking anything away from your prior
successes at other networks and other
shows what is it about this show
that you think has catapulted it to the
level that it is what's unique about it
well i don't have any sense of you know
i'm i'm the least software person in the
world by design i think self-awareness
leads to self-obsession which leads to
self-pity which leads to misery so i
really try not to think about myself
um
but if i'm being completely honest about
it i think it it's pretty simple like
i've hosted a lot of shows on multiple
networks
and it really depends on the network
you know if you're hosting a show on a
channel that nobody watches then
nobody's watching you know what i mean
it's like you host a show on fox right
now
and speak to relevant issues you can't
but help get a big audience and that's
kind of so i'm not being falsely modest
i'm being sincere because i i've lived
it i think it really has a lot to do
with you know the 8 pm show and fox is
just an amazing piece of real estate um
i know that personally i'm 52 so i've
really kind of run out of any interest
at all in what liars say
so for example 20 years ago if someone
had ever called me a white supremacist i
think i would have been paralyzed with
horror because that's an awful thing to
call someone's awful thing to be and i'm
of course not
but now
i really i've realized just having grown
older that like the people saying that
don't mean it at all you know the first
time someone called me that i went on tv
and said no actually you know i'm i've
got really pretty liberal racial views i
think we're all the same everyone's
created by god i'm a christian i think
we have identical value and i really
mean that and i do think that and so i
hope this clears it up he's a white
supremacist and that's when i realized
they don't care what you say no there's
no
there's no point right so the only
reason they're saying that is in order
to control you through fear
and i'm just old enough that i'm not at
all afraid i know exactly who i am i
have weaknesses that's just not one of
them now if they call me out one of my
weaknesses
if they're like like what i don't know
we notice that you gain and lose 50
pounds a year like maybe you could get
your you know snacking under control
that would probably hurt my feelings a
little bit because that's totally real
what's what's your worst like guilty
pleasure
i mean you know i'll eat anything bad
um i think partly it's
well it's just a lack of self-control or
you know i write a lot you know that's
essentially my job is to write and so
i think when you know you're totally
absorbed in writing something every day
you kind of give yourself permission in
a very self-indulgent way to eat crappy
food and that's whatever i mean it's
just and part of it is just
just laziness you know rather than make
a meal or go find a meal
you know if someone were to put a bunch
of fig newtons in my house and probably
eat them it's like here they are right
so that's like an actual fault or
sometimes i get mad you know i have a
temper that's a totally fair criticism
and i take that seriously
but the other criticisms that are not
real at all they're not even close to
real i sincerely don't care i just don't
care so that's a strength if you don't
care
and you that means you can't they don't
have a leash on you like they're not
controlling but they try of course and
there's this whole almost cottage
industry there's a whole group of people
devoted seemingly
to criticizing you and trying to get you
fired and canceled every day
do you ever think about them when you're
planning the program like even to give
them middle fingers on a nightly basis
it's funny if you knew how cut off i was
by design i don't think anyone would
actually really believe it
but i just i lead a very different kind
of life you know i'm not interested in
participating in that i don't like the
internet
i think technology is for the most part
poison i'm for mris you know for
chemotherapy but in general technology
has not liberated us it's enslaved us
and it makes people unhappy
and it divides them from each other and
i just don't participate you know i
don't like the internet at all and i
don't go there i don't do social media i
hate social media so how do you build a
nightly show if you're cut off to some
text message
through text messages with your team no
no with hundreds of people so i
get daily texts from probably a couple
hundred at least people i know around
the country world really who i've known
for a long time have got good judgment
who are in different
worlds living different kinds of lives
who send me stuff and that's the primary
way that i understand the world and it's
almost like having a team of course i
know this sounds very weird but it's 100
ask anybody who works with me it's true
and um
and then in my private life i really try
and read books
i don't i think the internet is so
misleading it gives the google gives the
illusion of access to knowledge when in
fact it's a tightly constrained world
constrained by people with the worst
possible motives you know so if you want
to understand
what's happening in the world read
history and i i do i mean i have a lot
of faults but i do read every day book
you know actual paper they're made out
of paper
so that's what so like i have no sense
of it so the only time i ever get any
sense of it is on you know if i go into
public with one of my kids and someone
starts screaming at me i'm like totally
baffled by it why are you mad at me but
apparently there is
quite a bit of opposition to our show
but none of it ever filters down to me
at all i last thing i'll say is i listen
very very carefully to the negative
opinions of people i respect and trust
so it's not that i'm impervious to
criticism i take it very seriously if my
wife thinks i've done something wrong
man i brood about it because i really
care i've been married 30 years i really
care what she thinks
my children close friends i have a
couple producers who i'm very close to
personally i listen very carefully to
them
so but what i don't do is listen to
people
who aren't speaking in good faith
who are stupid or unwise or whose own
lives are demonstrably disastrous like
why would i care what they think or like
malignant on purpose but they just have
no demonstrated record of success so
like would you buy real estate from a
homeless guy would you invest with
bernie madoff no then why would you take
personal life advice from someone whose
personal life is in disarray like i
would never do that because i'm not an
idiot so i listen to people who are
impressive
and there are a million people i know
who are more impressive than i am and i
listen very carefully to what they say
um but i'm absolutely not going to
listen to like cnn
why would i care what they say i just i
literally don't care
you and i appeared on gut fell briefly
together because you were having a
debate a formal debate with greg about
who the dumbest person on cnn was and
you had a very strong opinion on that
there was another network mentioned at
one point and another
uh anchor these days at that network and
i believe you went out of your way not
to mention her name i will you don't
have to but nicole wallace yesterday
referred to or compared our network fox
news to terrorists and i wonder you can
you can engage with her or not but with
this
wildly overheated rhetoric i mean what
drives that do they believe it are they
angry that were well i haven't seen
nicole i've known nicole for you know
more than 20 years nicole when i knew
her was called nicole devenish and she
was a flak she was a
you know a spin person she worked for
jeb bush who was then governor of
florida
and she was is what they call a
communications director or something so
people like that you know have their
merits have their values they're not all
evil or anything but that their job
description is lying they lie for a
living they'll say what they're told to
say they'll say what they have to say
they're not involved in even the
theoretical pursuit of truth
and i don't think that she has changed
her orientation ever since like whatever
drives nicole wallace i mean i find her
unusually
venomous and lacking credibility and
repulsive actually but that's just a gut
reaction that i have because i've known
her for so long and i respect her so
little
but that whole category of people
is really shocking to me look you're on
tv okay people some percentage are
taking you seriously
i
in my show i'm afraid of what's
happening in a lot of ways the country
and i say that and i know that that
probably freaks people out
but i really try not to make people more
afraid than i think is warranted last
night for example we did a piece on the
riots of the summer of 2020 and we have
a lot of footage of those riots and some
of that footage is so shocking enough
being blunt with you so racially
divisive
that we don't put it on the air
at my request because i don't it's real
but i don't want to give people the
impression you think it's too much some
hellscape it's too much and television
is such a powerful medium you can really
evoke heavy-duty emotion in people
television is not about conveying facts
it's about conveying feelings emotion
so you should pause before you whip
people into a frenzy you really should i
don't always and that's my fault and i
should but i try to someone like nicole
devonish who has no
record of achieving anything in her life
like nicole what's the sum total of
nicole devenish's or whatever she's
calling herself now
like she's just
not an impressive person so in
place of actual achievement she tries to
be as extreme as she possibly can i
think
in this moment that's a moral failing i
mean it
let me ask you about a poll that i just
saw and it's interesting because what
you do often on tucker carlson tonight
and today and all the tucker carlson's
yeah is you will sometimes broach topics
that others
don't or won't yeah and and something
that has been discussed and you know
this whispered about a lot especially in
dc is the health and the mental fitness
of president bibe yeah now you have
major pollsters actually asking
questions about it and this politico
story has it's a 4648 split is the guy
uh mentally sharp or the exact term was
mentally fit for the job with 48 of
plurality saying no he's not it's
interesting to see that conversation
which was very harsh sort of off limits
for quite some time
starting to bubble up a little bit more
openly i wonder what your thoughts are
on that well i'm so divided internally
on the subject i have such mixed
feelings about it because
yes he is going see now obviously and
but just to tell you i know that i've
known joe biden for 30 years i always
liked joe biden for whatever it's worth
very warm person never agreed with him
but i never hated him at all i always
liked joe biden i know a bunch of
members of his family and i some a
couple of them very well and i knew for
a fact that the certain members of the
family were very concerned about his
cognitive ability they didn't expect him
to get the nomination nobody did and he
got it and they were freaked out about
it that's i'm not speculating i know
that for a fact so i knew that the
family believed he was in cognitive
decline
so there's that and that's news that's
news on the other hand i'm a human being
i'm 52 like i hope i make it to 78. i
think there's nothing sadder than
someone losing his mind
i think that's that
with relatives of course people you
really love yeah i respect old people
that's the other thing i just
instinctively respect old people they've
been around longer i aspire to be able
to exactly thank you nicely put i aspire
to be an old person
and so the maca man senility is like i'm
not gonna do that i probably have
because i've violated a lot of my
principles in the heat of the moment but
i try not to i don't want to be that guy
i want to treat old people with respect
even if i
you know abhor what they're doing
and so i'm not coming out every night
saying he's a vegetable well first of
all he's not a vegetable but he is in
decline look
pull up tape from joe biden four years
ago it's a totally different man so
everybody knows it i would just say as a
political matter i felt that his
obvious whatever you want to call it the
fact he was slowing down
was one of the reasons he got elected
because he seemed non-threatening so he
might be a little punchy he's clearly
not in his game whatever you you know
however kind of safe normal safe thank
you that's the word safe
and i got that i totally understood that
i know why people voted for biden i
definitely do i'm not mocking them for
voting for him they were exhausted by
trump they're not ideological they
didn't think about the ideas
that biden represents or the trump
represents or it's like trump is
freaking me out i need to get something
calm and that's why they voted biden i
understand it
what what we didn't understand is that
biden would be immediately taken over
and used as a vessel by people who
really have a hard ideological agenda
that is yeah how safe is it feeling
right now not at all and you know if
biden had come in and done things i
disagree with raised taxes or kept
troops in syria and i would have
complained about it because i don't
agree with those things however i
wouldn't have been afraid
you know if he had made good on his
promise to try to unite the country not
demonize whole segments of the
population the base of their back status
you know the worst thing that biden's
done in office so far is that press
conference where he said we're running
out of patience for you people who
haven't had the vaccine really first of
all
people are vaccinated according to
pfizer's own numbers
are not living longer than people who
aren't vaccinated in fact according to
the physician they're living a little
shorter they also are according to the
actual studies slightly more likely to
pass on the virus so like i'm not saying
there's no benefit to the vaccine i'm
not saying that what i am saying is
there's no basis upon which to demonize
people who haven't been vaccinated and
blame them for the freaking pandemic
that's totally evil that he did that was
totally evil talk about dividing the
country that's the worst thing i've ever
seen a president do i'm still mad about
it and no one's talked about the
vaccines because like you want to be an
anti-vaxxer i'm not an anti-vaxxer about
a million vaccines i'll probably have
many more my kids have had vaccines but
that is wrong that is totally wrong you
cannot force people to take medical
treatment against their will period
period not in this country because why
would we stop with corona
what about hiv or tuberculosis or do you
know what i mean like this is insane
and everyone's afraid to say it's insane
i'm not afraid because i'm i don't care
it isn't so you're not afraid to say
many things but that's just that's truly
nuts and we're going to wake up one
morning and be like i can't believe we
lived through that why didn't we say
something
it was all a dream except
it wasn't we're living it here at the
patriot awards in florida it's good to
see you tucker thanks for dropping by
like
guy benson as i was gonna like wind him
up and let him go but we have a break
tucker carlson tucker carlson tonight
every week night 8 p.m eastern fox news
channel good to see you sir thanks for
doing thanks man super fun appreciate it
we'll be right back